the other thing is watching actors save  a line they'll be in the middle of the  line and I know that they're halfway  toward [ __ ] that thing up and they're  going to they're going to pull the way  out of it yeah Shatner's the best at it  because I watch TJ Hooker so he's going  to almost butchering one and then fixing  it normally Shatner talks at a pretty  lightning fast pace  he's William Shatner he's talking and  when sometimes the lines aren't is  obvious damn he slows down becomes more  deliberate in his approach until he gets  it then he's back spitting up a guy dog  so some actors you'll save you can save  a line because you're like I'm not doing  this again  Wow you can see them actually doing yeah  Bru we see him bogged down